So today we're going to try and
do some laser diffraction,
hopefully with a view,
ultimately, to creating the
famous cross-shaped diffraction
pattern from the
helix that Watson and Crick
observed when they were doing
their X-ray diffraction
of DNA.
First mistake of the film, it
wasn't, of course, Crick and
Watson who did the X-ray
diffraction work on DNA.
It was...
Rosalind Franklin!
So first I need to go and get
the laser, obviously.
I thought I had one in here,
but it turns out I don't.
I have no idea when this might
have last been used.
So there's definitely something
going on there when
I pull the wire into the beam.
OK, so this looks a bit more
convincing, if you like.
We've got something interesting
happening.
Pretty definitely a diffraction
pattern going on there.
We've got some nice, dark
fringes and light fringes.
A bit of a mess in the middle,
but it's spreading all
the way over here.
There is definitely something
going on.
So what's happening is that the
laser beam is effectively
being cut into two
by the wire.
The wire is narrower than the
beams, so the beam is passing
around both sides.
And you can see all the
nice little, the
nice pattern of, er...
The waves add up and
you get a bright...
So anyway, they get
to the screen.
And because they both traveled,
erm, not the same
amount of, not the
same distance...
Anyway.
Don't know what you just did,
but it was good, yeah.
OK, so don't mind this little
light exclusion apparatus we
just had to set up here.
We can't really block out the
lights in the Prep Room at the
moment so we're having
to improvise.
But you can see so much more
structure now, obviously,
because of the slightly crazy
assortment of wires
that we've set up.
But we've got diffraction going
off all over the place.
And if you really look into the
structure of the pattern,
you can see this really fine
structure throughout the
two-dimensional field.
But you can imagine, that if
we went through the whole
process backwards, you could
work out from this pattern
where all those wires are.
Because if you move any one
of those wires then the
diffraction pattern is
going to change.
So if you could do the math,
then you could work out
exactly where all those wires
are from this pattern.
Imagine then doing that, not
with laser light, but with
X-rays, and, instead, not with
wires but with atoms. And that
is the basis of X-ray
crystallography.
Another day, another
diffraction target.
I'm going to remove the glass
as carefully as I can.
That will probably do.
So I think we've got, well
we've got a diffraction
pattern there.
It's a very, sort of, flat
cross but the axis of the
cross are very close together.
But I think that's what you'd
expect from a coil like this
because it's a very
tight coil.
If you remember the diffraction
pattern we got
from the vertical wires were
spread out into this
horizontal pattern.
Basically we've got that
happening from the coil from
two different, but not quite
perfectly aligned, sets of the
vertical wires.
We've got these, sort of, line
on the near side of the coil,
sort of, all lined
up together.
And then on the far side of the
coil we've got the same
thing but shifted very slightly
as the coil, sort of,
winds itself around.
So I think this is what I would
have expected to happen.
And if we, using my surgical
tweezers, if we just sort of
tease the filament out a bit.
Hopefully as we extend the coil
and we accentuate the
difference between the, sort
of, front and back of the
coil, we should see the
cross open out a bit.
And yeah, it's kind
of doing that.
Probably only so far I can pull
this before it breaks.
But, yeah, that's quite nice.
So we've got this really lovely
diffraction pattern
just from our light bulb
filament over there.
And this is very characteristic
of the
diffraction you get from
a helix or a coil or
something like that.
And it's what Rosalind Franklin
saw when she was
doing her X-ray diffraction
of DNA.
And it really influenced Crick
and Watson in determining the
structure and finding
this famous double
helix that is DNA.
And we've produced something
pretty similar here with a
light bulb and a laser pen.
And I think it's pretty good.
I'm quite pleased with it.